the prime numbers the prime numbers okay
by the way let's just quickly remember
what is a prime makes a number prime
yeah
okay so it's only factors right if you
wanted to divide it up by things are
the number itself there and one okay now
that's a that's a good definition i want
to i think there's a better one though
and the reason why is you might know
there was a trick
what's the very first prime number
remember yeah
it's two that's right now that raises
the question
why isn't one prime because you can
divide it by one and itself yeah no
oddness is going to be important for us
in a minute but i'm going to say
no that's not why because i will have
some odd numbers yeah
okay so one one only has one
factor one right so actually
a better definition for one of the prime
numbers is that the numbers which have
exactly two factors
two factors and two factors only okay
so therefore after two what's the next
one
two what's the next one
good now you will notice
that two is the one and only even prime
number
very very special okay now here's the
important metaphor the image that i want
to get in your head
okay the prime numbers in a very real
sense
they are the most important numbers in
all of maths
and math has a lot of numbers right
they're the most important here's why
here's why okay the primes this is what
you want to
jot down actually uh well the pros or
the prime numbers
the prime numbers are kind of like
in science you learn about this topic
called chemistry
right and within chemistry
you learn about these things called
elements okay now
not those okay now by the way the greeks
thought
yeah earth what a fire there's
but we've learned better we've learned
that there's things like nitrogen and
oxygen and carbon and so on
now these elements right mic carbon
hydrogen oxygen
and so on okay here's the amazing thing
about them
um i don't know how many elements
they're actually a science teacher i
think there's a hundred and something of
them okay
the amazing thing is though i think it's
amazing
is that every single thing in the world
from
whiteboard marketers to watches to uh
you
and i we're all made up of combinations
of these elements just
you take those and you put them together
in different ways and you get
everything prime numbers are the same
prime numbers are just like the elements
any number you can think of you can
build it with prime numbers okay you can
build it with these guys